There is no quick solution to all of
this,
but I want to,
of course,
the Security Council to use all the
tools available to them,
including sanctions,
looking at whether we can put
perpetrators to justice and to put them
on their lists.
Um,
I want the government in the DRC and
everywhere where this is a problem.
It's not only an African problem to take
this seriously.
Also to do everything they can to ensure
that we put an end to impunity,
to address the problem of impunity and
also to assist the women to empower
women to make sure that they have a
voice and a seat at the table where
decisions are made.
And so there are a number of things that
the UN has to ensure that in
peacekeeping operations,
we can protect the civilians.
And that means women,
that we have to look at the best ways to
protect civilians
when we are contacted by a lot of people
who have great ideas about to equip
women with everything from sort of small
weapons that could help them to defend
themselves,
to,
to a communication gadgets.
You know,
that they can,
um,
uh,
one other women that they can call for
help,
etc. And I,
I think everything is worth testing.
Uh,
you know,
we hAve to do everything,
but the,
the thing is it should not fall on the
women to actually also have to sort of
physIcally defend themselves.
This is a response.
It's not a women's issue.
This is a peace and security issue and
we have to make sure that we go after
the perpetrators.
So I would put much more focused on,
on fInding the perpetrators and
punishing them to close every exit,
every possible career possibility for,
for these guys so that they know that
there is no mercy for,
for rapists.